welcome to EE 380 Stanford colloquial
computer system spring 2018 2019
I'm Andy Freeman the other course
organizer is Dennis Allison seeing is
believing
that's not quite right seeing is
understanding well images have
relatively little information content
compare the number of bytes you need to
describe the slide up there with the
number of bytes you need to describe it
as an image it would just let us let us
humans see and understand things that we
wouldn't do as effectively if it was
text or some other form simulations are
another powerful tool to help us
understand systems and processes they
let us try alternatives run things at
faster or slower than normal speed and
otherwise replay the world up today's
talk is about using virtual simulation
I'm sorry visualized simulation to
effectively wargame physical
infrastructure the goal is to understand
threats consequences and the effects of
various responses thank you Andy and
thanks all of you for coming here I can
see some friendly faces in the audience
from way back in undergrad so it's great
to be here and some of you are related
to Singapore in one way or the other so
you might find this talk relevant in
more ways than just the content of this
talk so this talk is about virtual
reality in cyber physical systems and
how it leads to Smarter Cities so my lab
basically works on security and I'll
just tell you in a bit how we started
working on this field altogether so I'm
Sid and I'm a researcher at I trust so I
trust is the Center for research in
cybersecurity and it's the leading or a
cybersecurity center in Singapore it's
located in this very unique University
called the Singapore University of
Technology
design so this was set up by MIT in
collaboration with the Singapore
government to set up a multidisciplinary
non like non can unconventional
curriculum so we don't have fields like
computer science or mechanical
engineering humanities so there are
cross there are pillars instead so one
of them is the engineering product
development pillar so every undergrad
has to learn fabrication designing and
they need to learn how to program things
in the real life as well as in the
digital life so so it's a very unique
University in that sense and it's been
there for 10 years now
and my lab has been there for around six
years six of those years so I'm advised
by professor aditya mater who is the
director of iiterest and he also happens
to be the head of computer science at
Purdue University so he was he was the
person who was most excited when I told
him about this talk because he
collaborated with Professor Donald Knuth
on some review paper in the 1980s so he
so his experience goes way back he
started the first computer science
department in India so he's highly
revered in the field of computer science
so right now he's the director of this
lab and with him I work on fields like
virtual reality computer sign any field
of computer science so we mostly do
distributed systems and game design and
formal methods so all of these things to
contribute to security so these are so I
graduated from this university in India
from like there are familiar faces here
who graduated from the same place then I
worked at a at the Indian Space Research
Organization and collaborated with the
MIT Media Lab I spent two years at at an
investment bank as you can see and then
I made the jump to this lab where I work
at now so my first introduction to
virtual reality and teleoperation was in
this google Summer of Code project which
in vain
I had to build a teleoperation system
for humans who go to mass in the future
so this was in collaboration with the
European Space Agency so so the idea was
that the astronauts are safe inside a
habitat and they have to control the
rover outside so the asteroid walks on
an omnidirectional treadmill by wearing
a VR headset and whatever they see the
robot sees like whatever the robot sees
daysy
and whichever way they move the rover
has to move the same way so basically
the astronaut is an extension of the
robot that's moving outside this was
primarily because it's not safe for
humans to go outside into the Martian
environment even when we have fully
developed suits and everything so that
was oculus rift and development get one
which was one of the first headsets that
came out for virtual reality and it was
very painful to get anything working on
that if you have worked on that so what
I want to show you today is how far this
technology has come in just three years
and how far it is supposed to go so
first I will tell you why Singapore even
cares about security or virtual reality
so much so in in the defense budget they
are located thirty percent of the budget
to cyber security which is this is an
update from three months back so it's a
relatively new thing so the defense is
focused on these different pillars one
of them is military then social defense
in which we have social security for the
citizens then civil defence in which all
citizens have to go through Nash all the
men have to go through national service
at the age of 18 then economic defense
like all the economic safeguards that
are there to protect Singapore then
psychological and the latest pillar that
they added which is digital defence
which includes all the cyber security
and cyber physical systems research that
we do so recently my lab got funded in
seven figures to make Singapore the
primary hub for cyber security
research so that's why this talk is
based on that one more thing like
Singapore is Singapore open the world's
first virtual reality theme park which
like just a few months back so even the
virtual reality was pioneered in this
country it is being commercialized in
Asia more so this is a Korean theme park
which opened in Singapore very recently
and they have levels for different kinds
of people depending on their skill level
in virtual reality so if you have motion
sickness you can use easier rides VR
rides and they have things like
harnesses and stuff to make you as
immersive as possible so I'll just so
the title had this term cyber-physical
system in it which might be new to some
of us so I'll just basically focus on
what it means so we start with cyber
physical system is anything with a
sensor and an actuator which is
controlled by a computer so everything
is a cyber physical system from the
lights in this room to your mobile
phones to smart cars to your power grids
of your cities everything's a cyber
physical system so it's called cyber
physical because it has both cyber
components and physical components and
both can be controlled via the other so
you can control your physical components
through the cyber medium and you can
impact physical thing you can impact
cyber things through the physical medium
so this is a very formal definition of
cyber physical system so I'll just price
things up a bit and for the young people
in this room who grew up watching Iron
Man that is a very excellent example of
cyber physical system and I'll use this
example to show the different kinds of
attacks that are possible in a cyber
physical system so so cybersecurity in
the traditional sense only had cyber
attacks in which your computer was
infected with a virus and then it slowed
down the computer or it snooped on your
files or something but when you add a
physical dimension to it if the class of
attacks just widens much further so you
have all these four possibilities in
which you do si
attack which has a physical consequence
you have a cyber attack which does only
a cyber consequence you have a physical
attack which there's a cyber which has a
cyber effect and a physical attack which
just has a physical effect so without
spoiling anything from the latest movie
you can so this is one of the kinds of
physical cyber attacks so let's say you
your smart car meets with an accident so
that somehow damages the on-board
computer so that's a kind of a physical
cyberattack because a physical impact on
your system impacted the cyber processes
of the system so this can have both a
cyber and physical impact what my lab
mainly focuses on is a cyber physical
attack in which you hack which is the
traditional way in which we know cyber
physical attacks you hack into some
system you get access to it then you
control the physical components so if
you remember this scene from Iron Man 2
so the the hacker just bought into the
iron soldier and controlled the whole
fleet of iron control the whole fleet of
these suits to like just wreak havoc on
the city so this is not just a science
fiction example this actually happened
in 2016 the power grid of Ukraine was
controlled by hackers and they got the
city down for two two whole days in the
middle of the winter so so that is a big
thing which is happening these days and
that's why we need ways to detect these
attacks and avoid such attacks so the
domain which I'll be focusing on today
is a water treatment plant and I'll
explain why very soon so to establish
the correlation between a cyber physical
system and a water treatment plant so
all your manufacturing plants nuclear
plants these are all cyber physical
systems which are called critic critical
infrastructures because they control
they have a very huge impact on the
economy of a country so so everything
all these plants have one thing in
common they have a very similar
architecture so you see a historian
database in which
the plant operations get stored like
what's the level of the water right now
and like everything gets stored in a
central centralized database then you
have program programmable logic
controllers in which there are
algorithms which decide how to what to
do in a particular process so for
example the pump should turn on if the
water level is low so this is a very
sequential programming like this is a
sequential style of programming called
ladder logic in which every step has to
happen in sequence so these things
control sensors and actuators so they
get the data from the sensors they
estimate the state of the plant then
they control the processes using the
actuators so the architecture is
somewhat like this you have a physical
you have a physical process which is
control which is estimated by the sensor
then the PLC reads the sensor readings
then the actuator then the PLC tells the
actuator what to do and it impacts the
physical process so there's a good thing
about these PLC's is that they are
localized to the stage in which they
operate so if you have six stages let's
say ultrafiltration dechlorination and
all these different stages in a water
plant every stage will have its own
local computer deciding its own local
actions all of these computers are
connected to a centralized computer
called the supervisory control and data
acquisition unit or the SCADA system so
these blue stars indicate that all of
these points are prone to attack so so
what we did at the lab is we put defense
mechanisms at each of these points and
one of the things up one of the things
I'll be demonstrating is how to
visualize defense and how to visualize
attacks so for example these are the
electrical wires that go from the
sensors to the PLC so we went a step
ahead of all the things that are out in
the industry and we captured the
electrical current and voltage signals
and we assumed that a hacker cannot get
to the electrical and voltage signals
part because they typically focus on the
network part they get in through the
network so we so we capture data from
all these different levels and we have
and we have the most accurate state of
the plant so even if this stage is
attacked we have the lower stages to
tell us what the actual value of that
plant is by an attack I mean if the tank
is 80% full the attacker can report it's
just 20 percent full and that will just
mess up with the programming of the
entire plant that will tell the pump
that it should turn on and the tank is
actually 80% full so it will turn on
thinking it's 20% full and the tank will
overflow and you know what will happen
next
so what enables us to do all of this
stuff is that we have a hackable testbed
so our water treatment plant is as big
as this room and you can see that we
have access to each of the connections
in this room so I have just placed a
Raspberry Pi as a small project that we
were doing and that's not the only
testbed that we have in the plant so
this makes a lab one like the only place
in the world in which you have a water
treatment testbed a water distribution
testbed and Internet of Things testbed
and then on the power grid the good
thing about it is that all these are
connected so this means that you can
study cascading effects of attacks on
one on one particular testbed and see
its effects on another testbed so let's
say you had a smart home device in your
Internet of Things lab which got which
had a vulnerability which the hacker got
into so they somehow got into the lab
network then they moved to the power
grid
they attacked something in the power
grid which affected water treatment in
some way so since the water treatment
did not get power which it wanted to get
to operate properly this impacted the
water distribution in the city so it's a
cascading effect which we can study in
an environment like this so I'm just
coming from Kansas City in the
Department of Homeland Security's
conference on industrial control systems
so they are trying to build
a similar setup for all 16 critical
infrastructure sectors and like Japan
see Japan seems to be doing the same
thing so like we did this about six
years back so we have a lot of
collaborations around the world and some
of the best time series data sets that
you can get for real physical processes
which many people have requested for and
they use it for the for testing the
control systems methods or formal
methods or computer science methods to
detect attacks so this is just a quick
tour of the lab so this is one of the
stages then you go to the raw water
stage so you can see these are the
programmable logic controllers they are
always redundant then you then we have
installed different projects at
different stages so you have six stages
in a room as big as this and this is
just one of the test beds of the four
that I showed you and I'll be giving you
a closer look very soon so I want to
tell you how the world interacts with
this so you see the screen the operator
just operates it using the traditional
mouse or mouse and keyboard or touch
screen and the thing about these
interfaces is that they are hard-coded
by the vendor and they are frozen at the
release time of the plant so they do not
have any way to visualize attacks on the
system or different or if something is
under attack or any defense mechanisms
of the system all they tell you is the
value that the database is seen so if
that value is corrupted or hacked then
you have no way of telling what state
the plant is under so what hackers
typically do is they get remote access
remote desktop access to this particular
interface and that's how they usually
attack the plant so how they achieve
that is they send a phishing email to
the operator or they infect their thumb
drives with some virus which which is
how the Stuxnet attack also happened
if people in this room are aware of that
so now I'll just show you a quick demo
so what I have here is an oculus rift
headset so I'm being my position will be
tracked by these two sensors here and
I'll have for all the degrees of freedom
for my hand using these touch
controllers so you will be seeing a very
narrow view of what I will be seeing so
I urge you to try out the demo because
virtual reality is in 360 degrees and 3d
and what you are seeing is a 2d screen
with a very narrow field of view so you
won't be appreciating it as as you would
when you try this headset out so I'll
just start the demo now now because of
the space limitation it's not calibrated
as well but it should work hi welcome to
I trust our research focuses on the
development of advanced tools and
methodologies to ensure the security and
safety of current and future systems in
five key areas cyber physical systems or
CPS Internet of Things or IOT systems
enterprise just a thing
hi welcome to I trust our research
focuses on the development of advanced
tools and methodologies to ensure the
security and safety of current and
future systems in five key areas cyber
physical systems or CPS Internet of
Things or IOT systems enterprise
networks autonomous vehicles and
blockchain so yeah this is a digital
tour of my lab and this was just an
introduction I will walk you through my
lab so you see my hands here and you see
that I can make all kinds of gestures
here for different actions so let's just
walk through the lab we have the
following test beds for representing
different critical infrastructures SWAT
secure water treatment testbed body
water distribution and epic electric
power and intelligent control
I'm Aditya and I'll guide you through
this entire journey
follow the blue arrow and complete the
objective to move on to the next stage
of the tutorial so let's start with the
different interactions you can perform
with your controllers follow the signs
to complete the objectives so this is
just a place for people who use VR for
the first time they can just play and
see that we can modify physics as we
want so in this case we don't have
gravity as soon as you touch the ball so
so this is just a place to familiarize
the person the virtual reality
environment great job now let's show you
what to swat looks like all of these
components combine to accomplish
individual tasks and hence divided into
stages take a good look at them so you
have all kinds of freedom so I can move
around if I had more space and you will
move around in the VR environment as
well
I can squad if I want to and focus on
the particular components so these are
all the different sensors and actuators
we use in the lab so so the oil how I
let module and the pressure indicator p1
supply and storage treatment p3 ultra
filtration and backwash p4 the
chlorination system p5 rivers osmosis or
our pieces are all permeate transfer you
have backwash and cleaning that's the
network architecture of the lab now SWAT
consists of a modern six stage process
the process begins by taking in RO water
adding necessary chemicals to it
filtering it by an ultra filtration or
UF system dechlorinating it using
ultraviolet UV lamps and then feeding it
to a reverse osmosis or our own system a
backwash process cleans the membranes in
UF using the water produced by
oh the cyber portion of Swat consists of
a layered communications network
programmable logic controllers or PLC's
human-machine interfaces or hm eyes
supervisory control and data acquisition
or scatter workstation and a historian
data from census is available to the
scanner workstation and is recorded at
the historian for subsequent analysis
let's get you familiarized with the
monitoring screens click on the text on
the green screen using your hand mouse
or your laser pointer to in values for
the components so this is just to show
that you can work with a virtual
environment in the same way as a real
environment so you would have
touchscreen panels in the lab and you
can do that to the same things here so
this enables a lot of applications such
as remote teleoperation you don't even
need to be in the lab to work on the lab
and that's what we see in this demo look
around you and enter the simulated SWAT
by the door so if you visit my lab in
Singapore this is part of what you will
see so my space is where the scatter and
historian is managed from now let's go
take a look inside sort through the
glass door if you may so and present to
the area mafia doesn't hurt you before
so stage one called the raw water
processing stage raw water is stored in
tank t101 water comes into tank t101
through the motor as well behind the
tank water flows out of this tank to
stage 2 through the constant speed pump
here below these two a IT indicators
indicate the pH level and the oxidation
reduction potential or ORP of the RO
water in stage 2 called
the chemical dosing or
pretreatment stage appropriate levels of
three chemicals are added to the raw
water hydrochloric acid HCL sodium
chloride NaCl and sodium hypochlorite
and a ocean for disinfection dispersed
more people is affected if you are in
the water in this region or do all those
comes to control anti-roma later I just
focus on the general there is stage 3
the outer filtration stage this pump
here will move the water from tank t30
one through this UF or ultra filtration
unit to the tank t40 one the UF unit
contains micrometer membranes to remove
solid matter from incoming water this
stage contains a number of modern yeah
so one of the things that virtual
reality offers us is that we can
redesign the environment as we want so
it doesn't have to be a cluttered lab
layout like you just saw so what we did
was we laid out the lab again by
redesigning it you know very accessible
fashion so this is stage 4 stage 5 stage
6 and back to stage 1 so this this helps
us in visualizing a lot of things which
I will just show you so you you get more
context about the plant because you can
add as many assets that you want so I'll
just show you one of the applications
that we developed so instead of so walk
after and after cyber attack happens the
operator has to go through the database
logs and figure out what went wrong at
what step so that is a very tedious
process so what we did was we made that
process visual so you can see the plant
breathing you can see the plant moving
up and down at a speed which is not
we're not natural for the plant so water
is a very slow process like what a moves
up and down
very slowly so if you--if we speed that
process up we can see how the plant is
behaving like which at what point the
pump turned on at what point point which
wall closed so I'll just open an 11-day
dataset so that this is an 11-day data
set that I'll just play at a very fast
speed so you can visualize eleven days
in a few minutes so I left seven of
those eleven days were normal operation
and four days were attacks so we can see
both the both the cases when we when the
plant starts reading the data set so
anytime now it will just start so yeah
you can see the plant breathing so if
there's an attack on it will show it as
an attack and if there's a particular
component which is attacked it will turn
red and you can see the plant moving you
can see the different parts like the
pumps like if these things are green
that means the pumps are pumping water
to it and that's why the levels might be
increasing or decreasing in a particular
stage so you see all these values
changing which are the different sensor
values you can interact with the
touchscreen panels in the same way you
would do in a real plant
[Music]
so the reason you see two values here is
the is the same architecture that I
showed you earlier
so PLC is the reflected value of the
plant which may be hacked we developed
we developed a project for IC or
intelligent checkers which is the thing
that I told you in which we distribute
detection mechanism across the plant and
we measure all the values to see what's
the real what's the actual value of each
component in the plant so so you can see
the level Li t means the level sensor
and you can see that both these levels
are the same you can see the water going
up and down and if it's a critical
attack you can can alert the plant
operator accordingly and if you want to
slow down the rate of this data transfer
because water doesn't really move up and
down this fast you can do that so I'll
just show you that so if you look at the
time lapse rate it says fastest so now
I'll slow it down a bit so now you see
that it takes 0.3 seconds for every step
of the data set so now you see it move
very very slowly which is closer to the
real real situation in the plant so in
case there is an attack you can freeze
and analyze the situation of the plant
and see what went wrong which part was
attacked by the attacker first and you
can do all those kinds of analysis which
is important for recon
[Music]
so we did not stop at this we further
redesigned the plant and we added a
heads up display which you see very
partially here so what I am seeing is
something closer to this
so you see all these different
components and now I have a laser
pointer instead of my hands and you can
see my controllers so you have a map
mini-map here which shows you the
location of your of your character in
the plant so this is a small plant but
we when we extend this to a real-world
plant then these are huge plants across
multiple rooms so you need to know what
went wrong there so you can teleport to
any particular stage in the plant just
by focusing on it so I just clicked on
Stage four and I was teleported to state
four so state six so if there's an
attack here you can just go directly to
that stage and see what's going what's
wrong in that particular stage then we
have different detection mechanisms so
this might be of interest to people here
because it's physics based so invariants
are physical conditions which must be
true so the idea of this detection
mechanism is that the attacker can fool
the plant in whatever way they want but
they cannot fool the physics of the
system they cannot make water go at a
rate that's more than what gravity
allows it to go so so we have these
conditions that we derived both using
formal methods as well as machine
learning so that's another project that
I want to visualize through this virtual
reality environment so what this says is
if the motorized wall is open then the
water flow in the flow indicator should
be more than 0.5 so if it's not violated
it turns red and that's what this is
spying to show
so we can also see a summary of the
different things happening in the plant
like it's just an easier way to access
what's happening at each of those
fingers so from the pump one one zero
one is on which is true you can see it
it's been
and the pump 1:02 which is behind it is
off which you can see it's not it's not
green so that's why it's a one which is
the port for off
now I'll try to connect to my labs VPN
if it connect successfully he can access
the plant life through a virtual reality
environment
and I'll invite one of my lab members to
[Music]
so usually how this demo goes as I
connect my lap through the VPN and then
we do attacks here which you can
visualize here someone doesn't attack
there which you can visualize in this
environment so Salim is a researcher at
the lab with me and it's I guess 7:30
a.m. in Singapore so she'll just walk
you through SWAT so can you go inside
SWAT Sochi is in the control room right
yeah go inside so she's in the room next
to the test bed so she'll just show you
the different parts of the test bed and
she'll do a live attack there so she has
developed an attack tool in which we
work with vendors to attack the plant in
whatever way we want like
man-in-the-middle attacks or
network-based attacks or physical layer
attacks so we used the virtual reality
bit to demonstrate and visualize those
attacks so what you see here is stage 6
so Salima can change so you can see this
the value in stage 1 can you focus on
stage 1 yeah Ally t101 now you can see
that I mean the water level like I want
to show them the water level so you can
see it's close to 1100 right now and now
she can change it to some other value
using the interface that I showed you so
Salima can you modify it to 200 all
right let me go back to the yeah you can
do it from the touch screen right so
what you can do it from the touch screen
there okay it's open so no problem so
this focus on the monitor
see so you can see it says 600 it says
around 1100 and she can modify it to be
200 so this is our tack this is one way
how the plants are attacked there's a
disgruntled employee or an insider they
just want to mess with the plant they
still have their credentials after they
are fired so they can just remote access
remote desktop access to it and they can
modify it as they want we can also do
network-based attacks like using python
scripts so what she is trying to do is
she's trying to conceive made it 200 I
think and I change the I can't change
because the other thing is hi so no
change thank G the 200 is it okay yeah
okay and can you launch an attack from
your computer using pi comm set it up
yes I need Wi-Fi yeah
okay no problem so like if the VPN was
working I would you would have seen this
environment see the same values and you
can see what thing is being attacked at
what point and you can do an attack here
which she can show there and vice versa
so the idea is that this technology like
this enables teleoperation
so maybe your factory doesn't have
skilled workers to work on the 30 year
old PLC that you have so you can just
outsource it to some other countries
scale labor who can guide you through
the virtual reality environment and they
can guide the lesser scale person in
their country to see to modify the plant
because we are enables you to spatially
move around and like interact with
things so things which require you to
turn rotate and work with objects in the
3d space virtual reality has
to do that so you can easily do that
with with just a network connection so
okay while she sets it up I'll continue
with the rest of the presentation
so this this is also being used by the
water companies in Singapore so we are
working with the main Water Company and
soon power companies of Singapore for
training purposes as well so so this is
used to show the new employees how the
plant works and you can give them short
quizzes and while they are walking
through the plant to get how much of the
plant they know so the US Navy already
uses such a system for training their
new recruits on submarines even before
they enter the submarine so you can just
answer all these questions and see how
much you have grasped about the plant so
you can use this for training purposes
which is one of the main applications of
VR these days so all the companies use
it commercially for training purposes
and now I'll continue with the rest of
the presentation there is another demo
soon on another topic so stay tuned for
that so this project got like it's just
a seven-month-old project with just
three undergrad students the professor
and me so this has got a lot of
recognition since then it so it got an
award by the equivalent of Y Combinator
in Singapore so this this is a startup
accelerator which found this project
worthy enough for an award we had the US
Navy head of research visit our lab to
see the different technologies that we
have built at the lab so you can see my
lab director showing it to the US Navy
head of research then this was one of
the highest profile visits that we got
and that happened during sing up one of
the summits in Singapore so the
President of Chile visited our lab and
we had he actually wore the headset and
conducted live attacks on the plant so
that was a pretty big thing for us and
I've been on a mini talk tube and I
showed I gave this talk first at Kansas
City just three weeks back to the
Department of Homeland Security which is
the reason I
in u.s. right now so this is just the
beginning what we want to actually do
with this technology is we want to
visualize interconnected infrastructures
so we want to see the different layers
that driver city we want to see the city
level impact of different power grids
and nuclear grids and your transport
grids and how they how they affect each
other so we want to study cascading
effects and we want to develop in it
into a sort of a serious game which is
accessible for policymakers like
presidents and the heads of states so
that they can revise their security
policies so what we did is we took one
of the tools developed by the
Environmental Protection Agency here
called epinet so what epinet does is it
can help you simulate water distribution
networks very well so it's a simulator
and what my lab did is they added a
cyber physical attack portion to it so
you can have digital components and you
can affect the distribution in various
ways so this also got the best paper
award at the u.s. top US conference very
recently so we connected the simulator
to our virtual reality one of the
minigames that we developed so I'll just
show you that so I can show it to you
through my oculus rift and there's a
video as well
so what you see is a city and with just
a click of the button you can see the
water great portion of that city so you
can see how the city functions like
which tanks are being operated at what
time which pumps are on and you can see
the Nicola correlation between the tank
and the city in the city is water grids
so so this is one of the attack
scenarios that we have so there's a
distributed denial-of-service attack and
attacker has affected multiple PLC's
so you can you have to go and stop the
attack as the security as the person who
manages security in the city so first
you will focus on the water layer
because that's where the attack has
happened force so your physical
component has been affected so you have
to go and manually check that then
because it's originating from a cyber
point in the city so you have to face
the attacker and see at which point that
attacker is in the city so you see that
the cyber attack is coming from
somewhere there in the city so you try
to go to that physical location trace
the attacker down
[Music]
so you stop the distributed
denial-of-service attack and now we will
see the negative demonstration in which
we are unable to stop the attack and we
will see the consequences of that
[Music]
so now this is a realistic scenario
because the speed at which these attacks
happen it's all mostly too late to do
anything about that so we are unable to
like guess what's happening so you're
just trying to see whether attacker is
and failing at
[Music]
so you see the similarity between the
tank in the city and the water gray and
because we are unable to stop the attack
it's overflowing the tank as you can see
just with a simple cyberattack the
attacker is able to overflow the time
and one of the consequences could be
this so so the point of this talk is
this is not a fictional scenario because
it has happened on power grids and
transport grids it can happen to any of
the critical infrastructures and nuclear
grids in the case of Stuxnet so it can
affect any any of the infrastructure so
because this talk had a mixed reality
component to it as well so the next
phase of the project is to use a headset
like hololens and develop something like
the demo that they just showed two
months back so this is an Augmented
mixed reality had said they released
very very recently while this experience
offers significant benefits from a time
and cost of training perspective thus
far it's only been geared for individual
participation but now let's make it more
collaborative by leveraging the azure
spatial anchor service within view for
estudio and veal we can let Maria
seamlessly join in Alex's experience
Maria can simply take out her iPad and
launch view for you view once Maria
points her iPad at the same location
where Alex plays the blower she can
participate in the mixed reality
experience making it far more
interactive and collaborative that's
right Jim now that Alex and I can share
the same experience I can create a
number of different training scenarios
Alex let's simulate a gear failure mode
oh oh I see their gear vibration went
down and I have here threshold exceeded
please inspect let's go ahead and select
that
Alex I think you might be dealing with a
broken gear tooth and you will probably
have to replace the gear assembly
all right I'll roll up my sleeves and
get some work done here let's do it I'm
ready right I'm gonna start that this
assembly instructions for the gear
assembly so these people don't have to
be in the same physical location they
can be in there - no graphically
different places now that alex is using
hololens - he has access to a wide range
of hand and eye tracking capabilities
they're all available and before your
studio and view all right let's put it
back that is so awesome
euphoria studio a lot so as as we get
more and more sensors in our plants we
can develop applications like these and
use it for asset maintenance and see
which of the parts of the plant have
degraded in quality over their lifetime
and replace them right from your virtual
reality environment so before I
summarize the talk I just walk you
through the lab to see if
[Music]
so we saw that it can be used for such
an environment can be used for
simulation training for operation and
maintenance staff you can walk them
through the plant even before the plant
is built and train them on different
scenarios in the plant you can have a
very distraction-free interface so what
typically happens in these plants is you
have 20 screens and the operator always
misses the true positive signal when
when an attack is happening so because
of such information overload it is
important to design better interfaces
which have a very focused view on which
attack is happening at what point or
which malfunction is happening at which
component so an ER environment forces
you to be in a very distraction-free
environment you cannot really look in
the real world unless you want to so
unless you remove the headset so so once
these headsets get comfortable it will
be it can be a replacement for monitor
based interfaces then you can visualize
abnormal operation and cyberattacks like
floods and explosions so I did not show
you that part yet I'll just show you
so this is one of the happens
[Music]
even before it's flooding and if you
think this is a fictional Khan's
fictional scenario we have flooded our
own lab on two occasions so we know that
it's very much possible and that's why
it's a test bed and we can afford to
make these mistakes but you cannot do
this in a government-owned water plant
or nuclear grid so that's why we need
better security techniques to detect
these attacks and which is why the
research and these visualizing
visualization tools come into picture so
we saw that we can visualize defense
mechanisms so we can see which parts of
the plant are being attacked we can see
the the direction that the attack is
flowing in we can understand the
attackers intentions so an attacker use
is usually very smart so they do not
just do a full-blown attack right on
getting the access to the test bed so
even in the case of Stuxnet they waited
for a long time in the order of months
to understand the whole plant so they
used to just do small slight
modifications which went unnoticed by
the plant operators so they they
understood and reeked did a full recon
on the plant for more than a few months
so before they launched the full blown
attack in which they stopped the
centrifuge which affected the
manufacturing in that nuclear plant
so understanding the attackers
intentions is very important so they
might start an attack from a pump but
that does not mean the pump was their
main focus they might be affecting some
other component in some other stage so
using a tool using a visualization tool
in which you can see cyberattacks you
can see the direction that an attack
flows in and you can gauge the
intentions of that attacker even before
the attack happens and this is one of
the things that I am most excited about
so with the help of VR people in
Stanford or anywhere in the world they
can collaborate with us on
Spets they can conduct experiments of
what whatever kind of experiments they
can test the defense mechanisms they can
move around the plant conduct attacks
and collect data from the plant so this
enables you you to do it remotely and
you don't have to fly to Singapore all
the way to do this so virtual reality as
a remote collaboration tool is very
promising so that's why one of the demos
that I wanted to show with the VPN
working was to connect you to the lab
and see the two-way relation that this
is an extension of the real lab and the
lab is an extension of the virtual world
so that is asset maintenance was the
mixed reality demo that I had showed you
and we can use this as a city manager to
visualize interconnected infrastructures
so you can see the water layer of the
city the power layer and you can see
what kinds of attacks at what layer
might affect the city so so
interconnected infrastructure is going
to be a very important topic for smart
cities so this virtual reality and mixed
reality technologies can come in handy
big time there so thank you for taking
the time to come out to this colloquium
and it's been privileged to speak here
and go around the states and talk about
this research so I'm here in San
Francisco for about a week more and I be
returning to my lab after that so if you
want to connect with me just like reach
out to me after the talk or connect via
a link then you can just point point
your phone to the QR code it will take
you there so thank you so any questions
or comments that's the end of the top
you